i'd honestly rather be anywhere else but
the los
angeles courthouse right now like maybe
picking art with heather for our project
but i gotta do what i gotta do and this
is what's best for my kiddos
i'm gonna commend you for what you share
on the show because it's a lot
thank you yeah it's uh it is a lot and
i didn't you know when we first started
shooting
shooting filming um you know what
happened with my children's father that
happened
probably two weeks into filming so it's
not like i went into filming
in this in that position in this
position i don't know what it is
but i feel like i'm gonna maybe have to
um like get full custody of them oh my
god
at this point you know legally we still
have 50 50 but
i don't know where he is so i need to be
able to make decisions
without his signature his approval you
know we filmed for like seven
seven seven and a half months when he
still was nowhere to be found it's like
this is a huge part of my life
and i have cameras following me 24 7.
there's you can't you can't hide so he's
still
you haven't heard from him it's it's
almost a year ago
it'll be a year on august 26th wow i
mean do you have
fears of what happened or have any
inclination of what happened
i have done every bit of i've speculated
to the point that i'm like
i mean i filed a missing person's report
at one point
i hired a private investigator at one
point they never got a visual they gave
me
a little insight of where they think
maybe i've reached out to every family
member
i've had friends reach out if i reach
out to his sister
and brother-in-law the next thing i
would be blocked i've
texted emailed voice messaged his mother
and his father
to no avail i've had at least 20
of his ex nfl teammate
um reach out to me saying like hey we
can't get all the crowd do you know i'm
like okay call me and then it's a whole
story his best friend of 20 years has no
idea like it's
we he's alive somewhere because
otherwise we would know
because there's so many people actively
trying
um and there's just no answers so
it's the most bizarre um heartbreaking
you know for my kids and
because it's not just their dad like
their whole that whole side of the
family has just
disappeared my mind is like okay if he's
had some sort of like
mental breakdown or you know he played
in the nfl for 11 years i
have to wonder if maybe cte like there's
those are real
things so even if that were the case
um his family didn't his family doesn't
have brain damage his family's not like
you know strong islands i don't even
know but um so yeah it's heartbreaking
but
um i've reached out to him you know his
phone is off
he has no social media like there's
nothing but i email and i say
you know and i'm not i go from being
like angry to just like really sad
and it's like this um because i'm still
you know i'm picking up the pieces and
mending little broken hearts
over here and so i haven't even really
like checked
in with myself when i do to see how i
feel it's like pissed or are you
desperate to find him and like
rehabilitate him in some way so that
you can get him back so i'll i'll reach
out one email will be like
okay where are you and then the next
email will be like
i want to help you let let us help you
like let me fix you what's going on like
your kids need you where do things stand
now
you still have full custody and i don't
legally
because you know he was such an amazing
father we never
when we got divorced it was i was
adamant that we have 50 50 because i'm
not that kind of person that would ever
want
my kids to not see their father as much
as they see me it's like you have two
good parents
you should experience both of them um so
but
what i've been told and what i'm
learning is once you go into it with
50 50 it's really hard to then switch
that to full custom so i still
don't legally have full custody of them
however
he's still in m.i.a so they are with me
full-time and um if he
knocked on the door right now and wanted
to see them it would be i would probably
go to jail because that would not happen
i would need answers i need
um so they're mine right now um and
we're adjusting and
it's okay but the struggle still what
kind of
conversations then do you have with the
kids about
what's going on um you know the con
because it's been so long sadly like
those conversations have
like the time between those
conversations has lengthened
it used to be you know at first nightly
if one of them wasn't crying themselves
to sleep the other one was and i
from the beginning and i have and i
still stick to this and i tell them
you know daddy isn't
well something and they're young but
they're smart and so
you know i bought a book called when the
brain breaks and it
shows that this is a healthy brain and
this is a brain that gets sick and it's
like a sickness when you don't feel well
so when your brain gets sick
sometimes you say things you don't mean
or you make poor choices you make
bad decisions and i said you know
daddy's taking this time
to figure himself out and get better so
that he can come back and be the dad
that we know he is
um his brain is sick and it's not it's
not anything you guys did
and i tell them um you know daddy loves
you very much because
he he if he didn't he would have
continued to try to care for you
in this you know with a sick brain and
instead he he gave you over to me
and trusted that mommy would be there to
you know
make sure you are okay until he can get
better but i mean that conversation
you can only say so much and then
they're smart they're like oh what about
grab them all they're gonna
put about this what about uncle you know
so
it's been it's been a lot for them
and they are adjusting i mean i couldn't
ask
for more amazing kids they're so strong
and it sucks that they have to be but
everybody always says that kids are so
resilient they really are
i wish they didn't have to be so much
but i'm really grateful that
that they are i mean they could be
rightfully so they could be
really messed up right now and and
they're not they're happy and thriving
and they're smart and they make great
grades and they have tons of friends and
they're athletic and funny and
kind of cute
you